these iconic monuments
are just shouting screaming at us
power dominance control
i feel about this i feel so
insignificant
together
these pyramids and the sphinx and the
temples create a landscape of power
[Music]
the huge sculpture protects the
necropolis
a giant symbol of supremacy believed by
many to have the face of khufu's son
kathrae
owner of giza's second largest pyramid
despite many visits here john has never
been up close
today he's been granted special access
to explore its enclosure
[Music]
it's absolutely inspiring i mean it's
just
jaw drop out
i've waited 50 years to be here
and now i'm here
it's just wow
66 feet high the sphinx gazes east
towards the rising sun
i know what it's like to work
with the living rock and how to carve it
this would have been a monumental
challenge nearly had copper chisels
wooden mallets
it would have been a harsh environment
this dust would have been everywhere
and yet
the workmen the craftsmen the masons
they were all willing participants
loyal to pharaoh
it would have taken thousands of people
decades to construct the epic monuments
of giza
but there's no evidence the pharaohs
enslaved people to build them
they didn't draw their power over the
people from force
john believes what stood these kings
apart
was that they inspired devotion
the sheer volume
of stone has gone into building this and
each
individual block represents the loyalty
that they had for pharaoh
the huge monuments of giza represent the
peak of the pyramid age
so why was nothing built on this scale
again
at the height of khufu's rain reliable
seasonal rains fed the crops that
ensured egypt's prosperity
for three months every year the nile
flooded and inundated the farmland so
farmers couldn't work the fields
the farmers were free to help build the
king's enormous tomb
they believed he kept the gods content
and the country fed
but soon after khufu completed his
pyramid
egypt began to suffer drought
[Music]
as crop yields crashed so did the taxes
coming into the state's treasuries
and despite the free labor the giza
monuments almost bankrupted egypt
the people's loyalty began to falter
the king's tombs that followed got
smaller
while khufu's great pyramid remained
dominating the niles west bank
the sheer power that he held
is absolutely
unbelievable
it was a power his struggling successors
were desperate to replicate
at abu
ghraib italian archaeologist
massimiliano natsolo wants to know how
the kings of the pyramid age held onto
power as their wealth and status
declined
[Music]
he has spent his entire career trying to
understand a very different monumental
structure
[Music]
an enigma whose mysteries captured his
imagination in his very first student
course in egyptology
this enormous scatter of ancient rubble
was once a sun temple
dedicated to the most powerful god of
the pyramid age
each king wanted a pyramid for achieving
his resurrection but this was not enough
for the fifth dynasty kings they wanted
something more
the king built this place to turn
himself into a god
the sun god
the pharaoh knew sarah didn't just want
to become divine in death
he built this temple because he wanted
to be worshipped as a god while he was
still alive
rising from the desert was an enormous
obelisk
the centerpiece of the temple
it was not a traditional slender stone
needle but shaped more like a pyramid
monumental walls enclosed it creating a
courtyard in which people could come to
worship the sun
the temple aligned perfectly on an
east-west axis with the path of the sun
so on the summer solstice every year the
sun rose through the entrance
traveled directly over the obelisk
and set at the western end
this alignment is identical to that of
the pyramids
records suggest that six of the pharaohs
who followed khufu decided to build a
sun temple as well as their pyramid to
underline their divine status to the
people of egypt
but almost all of these temples are lost
we know that there were six sun temples
and we actually so far have discovered
only two
max hopes excavating this sun temple
will shed light on these king's power
and perhaps help him crack one of the
biggest mysteries in egyptology and find
the other missing sun temples
the problem is
max is not the first to decode this
structure's secrets
early egyptologists excavated here more
than a hundred years ago
and left a mess of archaeological
confusion in their wake
well this fine is amazing
because it's a cover of matches left
by the archaeologists during their work
along with their discarded matchboxes
early 20th century excavators left 4 500
year old pottery scattered across the
site
as you can see here this area of the
temple is full of pot shirts but
unfortunately this material is
completely useless for us because it's
out of a secure context cannot tell us
anything about the life of the temple
if max can find undisturbed artifacts
they might reveal clues the first
archaeologists missed
even the smallest of fines could be
crucial in the hunt for the lost sun
temples of the pyramid age
[Music]
you